[Applause]
[Music]
the northerners in their islands were
disturbed taken away in the fray not one
stood before their hands from Quetta
code a car commish
Arvid a Lhasa they were wasted they set
up a camp in one place in a more they
desolated his people and his land like
that which is not
they came with fire prepared before them
forward to Egypt their main support was
Pella set theko shekel Esch denyen and
wish these lands were united and they
laid their hands upon the land as far as
the circle of the earth their hearts
were confident full of their plans King
Ramses the third the king himself he
says hearken to me all the land gathered
in one place the court the King's
children the butler's the youth all the
young men who are in this land give your
attention to my utterance that you may
know my plans for sustaining you alive
the new may learn of the might of my
father aim on creator of my beauty his
great might victorious against every
fallen foe beneath my feet he decrees to
me victory and his hand is with me so
that every invader of my boundary is
slain in my grasp his chosen one whom he
found among hundreds of thousands not a
single man among them to rescue them
from the
beause I surrounded her I established
her by my valiant mite when I arose like
the Sun as king over Egypt I protected
her I expelled for her the nine Mo's now
it happened through this God the Lord of
gods that I was prepared and armed to
trap them like wild fowl he furnished my
strength and caused my plans to prosper
I went forth directing these marvelous
things I equipped my frontier in za he
prepared before them the Chiefs the
captain of infantry the nobles I caused
to equip the Harbor mouths like a strong
wall with warships galleys and barges
they were manned completely from bow to
stern with valiant warriors bearing
their arms soldiers of all the choicest
of Egypt being like the lions roaring
upon the mountaintops the charioteers
were warriors and all good officers
ready at hand their horses were
quivering in their every limb ready to
crush the countries under their feet I
was the valiant Amon - stationed before
them that they might behold the
hand-to-hand fighting of my arms I King
Ramses the third was made a farce
striding hero conscious of his might
valiant to lead his army in the day of
battle
those who reached my boundary their seed
is not their heart and their soul are
finished forever and ever as for those
who had assembled before them on the see
the full flame was in their front before
the harbour mouths and a wall of metal
upon the shore surrounded them they were
dragged overturned and laid low upon the
beach slain and made heaps from Stern to
bow of their galleys but all their
things were cast upon the water then I
turned back the waters in remembrance of
Egypt when they mentioned my name in
their land made consume them while I sit
upon the throne of her Oktay and the
serpent diadem is fixed upon my head
like rah I permit not the countries to
see the boundaries of Egypt as for the
nine bows I have taken away their land
and their boundaries they are added to
mine their chiefs and their people come
to me with praise I carried out the
plans of the all Lord the August divine
Father Lord of the Gods their hands are
for me the shield of my body to ward off
evil and misfortune from my limbs the
king ruler of the nine bows Lord of the
two lands Rameses the third given life
stability satisfaction like rah for ever
and ever
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]